all right tanner so you've been a busy
sister you just wrapped another really
successful tour and I love that if I
chronically was called and they say we
don't have talent or they really do say
we don't know we just wrapped a little
meet-and-greet or it was really sick
when I don't do a meet-and-greet for a
while I don't mean my fans for a while I
kind of lose my mind so we just threw it
in there for the beginning of this year
but it was definitely just a taste for
my actual big tour this summer and I'm
so much more of a like performance-based
person anyway so I'm so excited to
perform music and meet all my fans this
summer and all that kind of stuff you're
out - some things I can tell I'm
steaming and it's you know it's so hard
for me to be quiet like it is to do
anything under the radar it's just like
the hardest thing for me I'm actually
losing my oh my god we're we're working
on two of probably the biggest projects
I was like my whole life right now and
it's two things that I'm just so
passionate about I've wanted to do since
I like made my first youtube video and
they're finally coming to fruition and
with everything in my past I think I
learned so much about taking your time
and doing things that absolute right way
or not doing them at all and feeling
like not only am i about to embark on
two of like my biggest dreams but
knowing that they're gonna be done like
absolutely the right way is like crazy
to me I don't know this really is like
Tanna 2.0 this year honestly I was like
Mike I started showing I'm like not a
mess I'm trying this is a whole new
woman honestly I think 2018 was like a
crazy year growing up so 2019 is kind of
like hey I grew up a little well so that
you've also been tweeting about like
other super a list labs like wanting to
work with you can you give any t at all
okay I mean we're doing a lot of really
crazy stuff with music right now music I
kinda had to put on a back burner for a
second now I'm back at it again so we're
doing a lot of crazy stuff in music I
have some really crazy YouTube videos
coming up with some of my favorite
people oh my god I suck at this right
now I'm giving you know - yeah speaking
music you got a really awesome shout out
from st. Dawson did you know that your
something's gonna be in a yes -
permission first how did that happen he
texted me like months ago like can I use
your song it's perfect for the end of
this video I was assuming it was gonna
be about like you know someone
you know like in a negative connotation
whatever and he's like no it just
it fits perfectly whatever and I'm like
of course you can like you don't have to
do this you've done enough charity work
for me like you don't have to do things
like now I really want to whatever and I
really was under the impression that he
was using like a lot of music throughout
it and then it was just gonna be like
four seconds of playing and in a random
clip and whatever and then to watch this
whole video kind of waiting for that
whatever and to see that he like ended
the entire like documentary with my song
and for him to use it for such an
emotional moment just like blew my mind
and then to see like thousands of
thousands of people tweeting me and like
streaming the song and listening and
being like I didn't even know you from
YouTube I just like loved the song or
like you know I didn't know you made
music I really like whatever it just I
don't know it really I did my fire for
music games and Fame and now they want
to use you
it's all crazy with the view
you've been super open about your
relationship with Brad that's not a huge
part of her life he's here when did you
decide to like make that public it's a
lot of youtubers feel like like this is
she probably bad when I keep this to
myself but you've been really open about
everything I think you and I both know
I'm just really bad at keeping things
private and me trying to hide a
relationship would just end up causing
ten times more chaos than me being
honest about it because it would just
blow up and exposed and when I just
rather exposed myself at this point
he's absolutely incredible and just so
supportive and it's awesome and we're
having so much fun like any talk with
like Brad or even like ballet because
obviously like she's such a big part of
life and there's so much love there yeah
is it how is that dynamic work when
you're introducing like you're a new
partner you know it's so crazy because
like when I step out of my life and I
look at it from someone else's
perspective I'm like damn like just
crazy like you know what I mean but to
me like I just I'm such an open honest
person in that regard and I just kind of
do whatever I want and I'm young and I'm
living my life and I kind of go out of
my way to surround myself with people
like that you don't I mean so to us
everything is just such a flow and it's
natural if that makes sense and nothing
is a big conversation or weird or
whatever because we're all the same in
that regard but then all my comments are
like he's going on I'm like I don't know
no I know everything just I'm so about
like showcasing life as it is you know
and I'm just like moment it's like
recording them and putting them out
there because like in that moment like I
was so happy like with that person that
time like hope is six months from now
it's entirely different like it I was
happy in that moment and that's out
there for her and it's sick to look back
on he did tweet about wanting kids are
you are you the next Lee is coming
boundary shaking oh she's doing just
fine her and the baby are rocking in a
cradle right now god no I think that no
one needs me to have a kid the fans me
Brad the kid itself it just it would be
an absolute disaster I've been thinking
babies are cute maybe that's because I'm
like in love right now we're like
whatever but
seriously that's a hard no mommy
blogging I was ready for oh my the baby
he's like scream crying in the corner
and I'm like losing my mind no it would
be absolutely terrible
[Music]